a real turning point in sri lankan
politics people have been waiting for
days for this official resignation to
come through and now i gotta buyer
rajapaksa is not only out of the country
but out of a job on the streets here
behind me though in the center of the
protest camp you almost wouldn't know it
it's so quiet there's been no mass
celebrations at all it seems that many
people are so exhausted by the whole
process by the political back and
forwards that they're just waiting to
see what transpires over the next few
days today we're expecting that the
prime minister will be sworn in as the
interim president parliament has decided
that it will meet on saturday to try and
form a unity government all of this
leading up to presidential elections
elected by the parliament on the 20th
of this month so that's where we're at
at the moment at the same time the
economic crisis here is as bad as ever
sri lanka is broke it has no foreign
currency left driving around the city
it's queues after cues
people lining up for petrol
for cooking gas for food
people don't have enough to eat
the protesters though say that their
struggle is not over they're concerned
that the prime minister about to become
interim presidents reynold wick
remasinga could end up running for
president they see him as a loyalist of
the rajapaksa family and they will not
accept him in a position in the
government so we'll have to wait and see
how that plays out but on thursday those
protesters pulled out of those
government buildings that they had been
occupying for the last few days
including their main prize the
presidential palace so for now things on
the street are very calm but it's an
uncertain environment that we're in here
politically in sri lanka at least for
the next week